[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
risiken ihnen allen einen schönen guten
abend katja stresow ist wieder bei mir
mit dem wichtigsten vom sport
schwül heiße angelegenheit heute dazu
später mehr das haben wir außerdem für
sie
ende nach wochenlanger belagerung in
mariupol sollen die letzten ukrainischen
soldaten im us werk kapitulieren
bahn frei für das 9 euro ticket ein
kurzes intermezzo für bus und bahn oder
ein echter baustein für die
verkehrswende
und überraschendes aus nach nur einer
saison vizemeister dortmund trennt sich
von cheftrainer marco rose
[Musik]
mario pohl die hafenstadt im süden mit
ihrem stahlwerk das zum symbol des
widerstandes gegen russlands
angriffskrieg wurde wird offenbar
aufgegeben die regierung in kiew soll
die verbliebenen kämpfer im stahlwerk
angewiesen haben die verteidigung
einzustellen russlands militärschläge
werden offenbar auch im donbass immer
stärker mehr von jürgen
klein stolz der russischen armee der
mehrfach raketenwerfern vom typ grad im
einsatz in der ost ukraine russlands
verteidigungsministerium liefert die
bilder der den kriegsverlauf belegen
sollen in moskau erklärt minister
schulden wir stehen kurz davor zusammen
mit dem militärischen kräften der
volksrepublik in lohans unter netz die
kontrolle über den bombast zu erlangen
direkt an der umkämpften frontlinien
noch unter ukrainischer kontrolle liegt
die stadt sevilla donetzk höchste zeit
die gefahrenzone zu verlassen die
ukraine zeigt bilder von
sicherheitskräften die kinder in warten
die busse bringen
hab keine angst okay es wird alles gut
sagte soldat zu den kleinen mädchen
macht mut lange hatten die menschen
ausgeharrt in der hoffnung dass die
front nicht näher rückt doch der
militärische druck der russen wächst ihr
offenbar stetig die lage in mariupol
scheint zugunsten der invasoren geklärt
nach wochenlanger belagerung melden die
russen und insgesamt mehr als 1700
gefangenen hier bilder aus der
vergangenen nacht keine angaben dazu aus
kiew aber offenbar eine neue anweisung
an den kommandeur der noch im stahlwerk
verschanzten resttruppe dieser erklärt
dazu per videobotschaft
hat befohlen leben zu bewahren und zu
schützen und deswegen die verteidigung
der stadt aufzugeben
noch ist nicht klar ob damit die
belagerung tatsächlich endet denn jahr
hätten die russen bald zusätzliche
truppen für den kampf in der ost ukraine
präsidentiellen ski spricht von einer
hölle im donbass russland meldet dort
erfolge wir sprechen mit johannes hano
für uns in kiew johannes wie ist die
situation in der ost ukraine
also praktisch die ganze ukraine lag
heute unter luftalarm immer wieder sind
die sirenen los gegangen auch hier in
kiew mehrfach am morgen wurde hier vor
kiel vereinen vor ort eine russische
rakete abgeschossen in odessa und
mehreren anderen städten hatte schwere
explosionen gegeben das ist russischer
raketen terror aber die leute haben sich
hier mittlerweile daran gewöhnt ganz
anders ist die situation tatsächlich
wohl im don was dort kämpfen sich
russische einheiten mit schwerer
artillerie dorf im dorf heran und ihr
ziel ist es die ukrainischen einheiten
einzuschließen dies stemmen sich wohl
mit allem was sie haben noch dagegen
aber die kräfte scheinen zu schwinden
und mir wurde inoffiziell bestätigt dass
die ukrainische verluste dort sehr sehr
viel größer sind als bislang offiziell
bekannt ist es geht jetzt darum wie man
mit der sache weiter oben geht die
russen wollen es einkreisen sollten sie
das tatsächlich schaffen wäre das ein
militärisch ist die saß dafür die
ukraine und das könnte den ganzen krieg
eine völlig neue wendung geben
dankeschön nach kiew johannes hano war
das lange war ja unklar wann genau die
ukraine mit den versprochenen gepa
panzern rechnen kann nach
zdf-informationen werden 15 dieser
flugabwehr panzer nun mitte juli an die
ukraine geliefert und zum paket gehört
auch ausbildungs unterstützung durch die
bundeswehr sowie munition
zur entlastung der bürger hat die
ampelkoalition diverse gesetze auf den
weg gebracht die heute vom bundesrat
beschlossen wurden erleichterungen
kommen bei der steuer bei der energie
dazu gleich mehr und es wird ab dem
ersten juni für drei monate das neun
euro ticket für bus und bahn geben ob
das angebot aber wirklich wie die
regierung nicht müde wird zu betonen
auch zur verkehrswende beiträgt daran
wird gezweifelt mehr von sven regn
eine der schönsten u-bahn-linien
deutschlands ist die u3 an den hamburger
landungsbrücken die bei touristen so
beliebte strecke ist auch drin im 9 euro
ticket ab ersten juni seit heute gibt es
die rabattierte monatskarte in der app
an den automaten und in vielen
kundenzentren zu kaufen ich finde es gut
nämlich ansonsten es ist ja bedeutend
teurer irgendwo hinzukommen ich denke
dass die das von kapazitäten her in den
bahnen fast sicher stellen können weil
er so einen anlauf wahrscheinlich sein
wird lässt sich schwer uns selbst gehen
die tickets sind deutschlandweit gültig
also egal ob in hamburg oder münchen
gekauft die straßenbahn in dresden ist
inklusive das gilt für alle öffentlichen
verkehrsmittel außer ic ec und ic e
das ist auch eine enorme
werbeveranstaltung für den öpnv und wir
sind wirklich sehr froh dass wir am ende
die geländer auch überzeugen konnten
einige bundesländer hatten bis zuletzt
mehr geld für den öpnv au insgesamt
gefordert und das soll auch mit den
erfahrungen aus dem neuen euro ticket im
herbst neu diskutiert werden die
verkehrsbetriebe würden ihre angebote
gerne attraktiver machen er geht zum
netzausbau oder geht es um
elektrifizierung der busflotte da geht
es um enge taktung geht es um andere
mobilitätsangebote und die müssen
geschaffen werden ich glaube das ist der
entscheidende hebel in stadtstaaten wie
hamburg ist das einfacher in
strukturschwachen gegenden aber fahren
mitunter zwei busse am tag da starten
selbst die hafenfähren an den
landungsbrücken häufiger auch diese
hafenrundfahrt ist ab dem ersten juni im
neuen euro ticket inklusive
apropos mobilität die tankstellen warnen
schon am ersten juni könne es lange
schlangen vor den zapfsäulen geben
möglicherweise sogar engpässe bei der
versorgung denn an diesem stichtag soll
der spritpreis sinken bundestag und
bundesrat haben auch einen steuerrabatt
beschlossen super könnte um 35 cent
billiger werden diese um 17 cent der
rabatt ist allerdings bis ende august
befristet vor allem pendler sollen
entlastet werden
die bundesregierung will ja weg vom
russischen gas dafür braucht sie neue
lieferanten und einer war heute in
berlin der emir von katar scheich tamim
al thani ab 2024 will katar flüssiggas
aus einer us anlage an der das emirat
beteiligt ist nach deutschland liefern
später dann gas aus einem feld im
persischen golf cart us-energieminister
und wirtschaftsminister habeck
unterzeichneten ein grundsatzpapier über
die energiepartnerschaft
bei den jüngsten landtagswahlen da gab
es auffällige dämpfer für spd und fdp
insofern spannend auf die frischen
zahlen des zdf politbarometers zu
blicken matthias fornoff ist bei uns
halo matthias wie fällt die
sonntagsfrage aus auf bundesebene naja
die politische landschaft die ist
jedenfalls kräftig in bewegung geraten
wenn schon am sonntag bundestagswahl
wäre käme die spd auf 22 prozent minus 3
die union überholt und wird stärkste
kraft 26 prozent plus 3 die grünen 24
prozent ebenfalls +3 fdp 7 - 2 hf dc1
linke 4 prozent unverändert
damit gäbe es mehrheiten für schwarz
grün und knapp auch für rot grün
matthias die lieferung schwerer waffen
von deutschland an die ukraine das wurde
zuletzt kontrovers diskutiert was denken
die befragten dazu naja das deutschland
der ukraine auch schwere waffen wie etwa
panzer liefert das findet eine mehrheit
von 58 prozent richtig 34 prozent lehnen
das ab
dafür sind im westen 62 im osten nur 41
prozent
angesichts der russischen aggression
gegen die ukraine haben finnland und
schweden ihren beitritt zur nato
beantragt eine solche nord erweiterung
der nato findet eine sehr deutliche
mehrheit von 81 prozent der befragten
gut 13 prozent finden das nicht gut ja
dann vielen dank matthias und wie immer
gilt das ausführliche zdf politbarometer
das gibt es eben heute journal ab 22 uhr
und schon jetzt finden sie alle zahlen
in unserer zdf heute app
altkanzler schröder gibt seinen
chefposten im aufsichtsrat des
russischen ölkonzerns rosneft auf das
kommt durchaus überraschend weil er in
der sache zuletzt ja beharrlich war und
es gab heftige kritik weil er sich nach
kriegsbeginn nicht von putin oder seinem
engagement für russische unternehmen
distanzierte und da wollen wir
nachfragen über mögliche beweggründe
wollen wir sprechen mit theo koll in
berlin tu warum jetzt und nicht schon
früher dieser schritt also die forderung
des eu-parlaments ist ja von vier großen
fraktionen tragen worden auch von den
sozialdemokraten und das dürfte ein
wichtiges warnsignal gewesen sein denn
obwohl ja kanzler scholz erst einmal
keinen grund sieht für die aufnahme von
gerhard schröder in die sanktionsliste
zeigt aber diese eu resolution doch die
mögliche politische dynamik die neben
den bisher schon 4000 personen auf der
liste dann künftig auch schröder
erfassen könnte er wird ausdrücklich
namentlich genannt und sollte es
wirklich dazu kommen dann träfe das ding
ja durchaus auch als genussmensch
bekannten gerhard schröder ziemlich
harten dann würde sein in europa
vorhandenes vermögen eingefroren
inklusive aller weiteren einkünfte dann
bliebe ihm eigentlich nur noch geld für
das nötigste für kleidung arznei und
essen und alle finanziellen bewegungen
würden überwacht von der bundesbank dem
wollte er jetzt wohl zuvorkommen es ist
insofern überraschend als schröder ja
den sozialen preis der
gesellschaftlichen ächtung den hatte er
ja längst voll bezahlt inklusive jetzt
der streichung seines bundestagsbüros
und der dortigen mit weiter stellen aber
ohne zugriff auf das eigene vermögen das
war dann vielleicht doch eine allzu
karge aussicht danke für die
einschätzung und schönes wochenende nach
berlin theo koll
die bundeswehr bleibt länger im
westafrikanischen mali der bundestag hat
das mandat um ein jahr verlängert
künftig können bis zu
1400 statt wie bisher 1100 deutsche
soldatinnen und soldaten an dem un
blauhelm einsatz teilnehmen für den fall
dass ihre sicherheit nicht mehr
gewährleistet ist gibt es im neuen
mandat eine ausstiegsklausel
schwere unwetter haben die meteorologen
für heute vorausgesagt mit regional
heftigen gewittern und starken böen
anfangs mit schwerpunkten über nordrhein
also da muss ich darüber mit
schwerpunkten über nordrhein-westfalen
und rheinland-pfalz und danach zog die
front dann weiter richtung osten aktuell
auf einer linie zwischen lüneburger
heide und nordbayern christoph distel
beginnt seinen bericht in rheinland
pfalz
bad neuenahr-ahrweiler heute nachmittag
regen aber normaler pegel der aa fliesst
ruhig am kurhaus scheiben kaputt die
wand weggebrochen es sind die alten
schäden von der katastrophe vor einem
jahr aber sie lassen den etwa verstehen
warum die anwohner dort gerade besonders
nervös sind
es war reinigend und jetzt
wie schwer das wetter gerade
auszurechnen ist zeigt der vergleich
normaler niederschlag in bad
neuenahr-ahrweiler aber nur 40 kilometer
flussabwärts dieses bild hagel in
neuwied etwa am 16
und weiter nördlich nordrhein-westfalen
paderborn eine einzelne gewitterzelle
wird zum tornado berichten anwohner
bäume knicken um erste müll alles
mögliche wirbelt durch die gegend es ist
wie angekündigt glück oder pech können
ein paar straßenzüge beieinander liegen
so ziehen die gewitter gerade von west
nach ost
noch werden keine schlimmeren schäden
oder verletzte gemeldet aber bis in die
nacht hinein könnte sich das schlagartig
ändern
wir wollen das mit unserem meteorologen
erst intelli vertiefen hallo ostern also
schwere unwetter dieser art kennt man im
grunde aus juli aus dem august warum
wird jetzt schon so heftig ja das hatte
mit dieser heißen luft zu tun die ja
teilweise auch über spanien und
frankreich liegt uns ja auch erreicht
hat die kammer aus nordafrika ja und
dazu kam noch die relativ kalte luft aus
dem norden und das war die explosive
mischung die eben dazu geführt hat dass
sich dieses gewittertief gebildet hat ja
und extremwetter nehmen ja immer weiter
zu das hat ja auch der weltklimarat
zuletzt auch bestätigt also sehr
außergewöhnlich für mal was passiert
jetzt mit diesem unwetter mit diesen
zellen in welche richtung bewegt sich
das ganze wäre die verlagern sich
ostwärts es gibt jetzt tatsächlich auch
ein tornado verdacht in lippstadt und da
gab's verwüstungen das muss man noch mal
überprüfen ob es tatsächlich ein tornado
war aber es gibt einen verdacht ja und
wir sehen auch auf dem satelliten film
was da los ist das ganze zieht
allmählich nach osten hin und diese
roten flecken die wir über deutschland
erkennen dass ein super zellen da können
durchaus tornados drin sein und wir
sehen das ist noch lange nicht vorbei
und das wandert weiter richtung berlin
und wird auch dort wahrscheinlich für
große schäden sorgen also das ganze
bitte nicht unterschätzen danke für die
infos märz leiten dann auch im anschluss
an unsere sendung im wetter standhält
vielen dank
in deutschland gibt es den ersten fall
von affen trocken das virus sei bei
einem patienten zweifelsfrei
festgestellt worden teilte das
bayerische gesundheitsministerium mit es
handelt sich um einen 26 jährigen
brasilianer er befindet sich seit einer
woche in deutschland und wird zurzeit in
einer klinik in münchen behandelt und
von dort berichtet jetzt petra neubauer
gut isoliert wird in der münchner klinik
schwabing der erste fall von affen
pocken in deutschland betreut ein
26-jähriger eingereist von portugal über
spanien nach deutschland sein zustand
derzeit gut er hat die typischen sag ich
mal pusteln auf der haut wird das von
affen pocken kennen aber er ist in
keinem bedrohlichen zustand wir gehen
davon aus dass der patient sich auf dem
europäischen festland infiziert hat es
gibt nur wenige aufnahmen von dieser
krankheit die ursprünglich aus dem
tierreich stammt infektionen beim
menschen wurden bislang fast nur in
einigen regionen afrikas festgestellt
doch nun häufen sich die fälle in
nordamerika und europa der verlauf hier
ist in der regel mit es gibt bisher
keine standardtherapie wo man jetzt
sagen könnte man nimmt so etwas wie ein
antibiotikum es gibt aber antivirale
mittel die auch viele verschiedene tiere
wirken die entsprechend eingesetzt
werden können es trifft vor allem
menschen mit vielen wechselnden
sexualkontakten und homosexuelle männer
immerhin soll die klassische
pockenimpfung die alle vor 1976
geborenen bekommen haben schützen
gefährdet wären demnach jüngere grund
zur panik sieht der
bundesgesundheitsminister dennoch nicht
ich gehe nicht davon aus dass wir eine
große dunkelziffer in deutschland zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt haben ich glaube dass
das ein sehr früher fall ist und dass
wir dort wo wir werden dem so ist dass
wir dann auch gute chancen haben die
fälle beherrschen zu können wie schnell
und wie leicht sich die affen pocken aus
bereiten lässt sich derzeit noch nicht
sagen nun gelte es daten zu sammeln und
bei entsprechenden symptomen wachsam zu
sein
so wir verlassen die erde der us
luftfahrtkonzern boeing will elon musk
und seinem raumfahrtunternehmen spacex
konkurrenz machen auf einer atlas rakete
startete das wiederverwendbaren
raumschiffs starliner vom
weltraumbahnhof cape canaveral zur iss
erst einmal ohne menschen an bord der
letzte versuch vor zweieinhalb jahren
war noch gescheitert schon bald soll der
star einer astronauten und material zur
iss bringen
wir sind beim sport wir sind bei katja
und es beginnt mit einem paukenschlag in
der tat für die meisten kamen dieser
schritt dann doch überraschend nach nur
knapp einem jahr zusammenarbeit gehen
borussia dortmund und trainer marco rose
getrennte wege große war für die
ablösesumme von fünf millionen euro aus
gladbach gekommen die bvb
verantwortlichen reagieren damit auf
eine saison ohne höhepunkte aus in der
champions league aus im dfb pokal gegen
st pauli und damit die titelverteidigung
nicht möglich in der bundesliga zwar
zweiter aber mit frustrierenden acht
punkte abstand hinter meister bayern die
danach notwendige saison kritik hat nun
zum ende der geschäftsbeziehung geführt
während unseres gesprächs ist ihm eher
der eindruck gereift dass die
hundertprozentige überzeugung aller
verantwortlichen nicht mehr vorhanden
ist letztlich haben wir uns deshalb
gemeinsam entschieden die zusammenarbeit
zu beenden ein kandidat für die
nachfolge könnte der derzeitige
technische direktor identisch sein der
2021 als interimstrainer mit dem bvb dfb
pokalsieger wurde
und auch trainer lucien favre wird als
bundesliga-rückkehrer hoch gehandelt und
zwar bei borussia mönchengladbach die
nach der entlassung von adi hütter auf
trainersuche sind oder eben vielleicht
waren fahrer hatte gladbach bereits von
2011 bis 2015 trainiert im ersten
relegationsspiel für die fußball
bundesliga zwischen hertha bsc und dem
hamburger sv hat der hsv mit 1 0
vorgelegt die berliner in weiß
weitestgehend ideen und harmlos der hsv
mit dem glückstreffer unterstützt vom
innenpfosten in der 57 minute das
rückspiel ist dann am montag in hamburg
und noch dies die deutsche eishockey
nationalmannschaft ist bei der wm in
finnland klar auf viertelfinalkurs durch
das 9 zu 4 heute gegen italien
das torfestival beginnt nach fünf
minuten alexander karat schuhen knackt
als erster italiens eis catenaccio 40
stets gegen den sieglosen
abstiegskandidaten nach dem ersten
drittel im zweiten trifft an lukas
reiche erst am vortag aus der zweiten
us-profiliga angereist ein paar
leistungsträger werden geschont vom
deutschen trainerstab zudem mit der
kanadierin jessica campell erstmals eine
frau gehört 61 führen sie vor dem
letzten drittel da gibt es noch drei
gegentreffer aber durch samuel so ramiz
auch das neunte eigene tor deutschland
gewinnt 9 zu 4 und ist ganz nah dran am
viertelfinale und ganz sicher drin am
sonntag wenn sie gegen kasachstan
gewinnen und diesen gruppenletzte also
sieht ganz gut aus jedenfalls klingt 94
ganz schön imposant dankeschön katja in
sachen wetter bitte vorsichtig bleiben
mehr dazu gleich mit es den termin um 22
uhr das heute journal mit christian
sievers von uns war es das schön dank
für das interesse noch einen entspannten
abend für sie und gerne bis morgen
[Musik]
schön kunde und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter jetzt am abend und in der nacht
in den nächsten stunden müssen wir
weiterhin mit extremen unwettern rechnen
dabei kann es orkanböen gehen heftiger
starkregen große orgel fünf zentimeter
oder einzelne tornados bei gewittern das
passiert dann aber lokal also in diesem
bereich durchaus aber nicht überall
schauen wie ist das passiert dieses tief
hier hat sich nach und nach entwickelt
und intensiviert am nachmittag und in
den abendstunden zieht dann in der nacht
raus im süden regnet es noch kräftig
weiter und auch in der mitte kann es
teilweise heftigen wind geben teils mit
orkanböen morgen im tagesverlauf dann im
norden schauer und auch gewitter im
süden auch noch sonst lockert es auf und
die sonne zeigt sich bei höchsten
temperaturen von 16 bis 18 grad im
norden und
27 grad ganz im südwesten die nächsten
tage es gibt schauer und gewitter im
süden noch am sonntag bis 26 grad sonst
lockert es auf und montag bekommen wir
neue unwetter im süden mit gewittern bei
20 bis 27 grad und damit ein schöner
abend